BRETT HESTERBERG:
All right, we'll
get the suspense through now.
Welcome, everyone, to IO302,
Optimizing Performance
on the Cloud SQL for MySQL.
Thanks for your patience as we
were getting started, there.
My name is Brett Hesterberg.
I'm a product manager at
Google working on Cloud SQL.
I'm joined today by
Stanley Feng and Ted Tso.
Stanley leads our storage and
database performance testing
teams in Google Cloud.
And for those of you who
are familiar with the Linux
ecosystem, Ted Tso may
not need any introduction.
Ted has been a longtime
Linux contributor
and is currently an ext4
file system maintainer.
Ext4 file system will show
up as an important point
in our discussion today.
Before we jump in, we'd love to
learn a little more about you.
So by a show of hands,
how many of you out there
are developers?
A good chunk of the room.
OK.
How about DevOps engineers?
A handful of DevOps engineers.
Great.
How many DBAs do
we have out there--
DataBase Administrators?
All right.
Good to see some hands going up.
How many reluctant DBAs
do we have out there?
Oh, a few more.
I'm not surprised.
And do we have any
managers in the audience?
Oh yeah, a few
brave managers here.
Good.
A couple more questions for you.
How many of you attended Google
Cloud Next last year, in 2017?
A handful of folks.
And anyone in that group attend
the Cloud SQL performance talk
last year at Google Cloud Next?
All right.
I think we've got a group of
first-timers for Cloud SQL
performance.
Thank you all for
joining us today.
Let's talk a little bit about
what we're going to cover.
And actually, before
I do that, let me just
go through just a few
room logistics in case
you haven't been
to a presentation
in a movie theater.
We have mics at the
front of the theater
here that we'll use for
Q&A. If you have questions,
please jot them
down as we go along.
We'd love to get those
addressed with the last five
to 10 minutes or so
of the presentation.
We also have members of
the Cloud SQL engineering
team in the audience.
They're sitting in one
of the front rows here.
They'll be available--
as will Stanley, Ted,
and myself-- after the talk
to answer your questions.
If you get a chance
and you have questions,
I highly encourage that you
talk with the engineers--
the folks who build the product.
And we'll get those addressed
in one fashion or another.
With that, what are we
talking about today?
We will start with a brief
Cloud SQL introduction
and then talk about how to
scale it up and scale it out.
From there, we'll get into a bit
more deeply technical content.
And you'll see as we go
through the presentation today
that it gets progressively
more technical.
We'll take a look back
to last year at Next.
We showed performance numbers
last year for Cloud SQL.
And we'll talk about how,
in the year that has passed,
we've been able to
increase Cloud SQL
performance by around double.
We'll talk about the tuning
parameters that went into it.
And then we'll talk a bit
more about our future work
here, which we're calling
16 kilobyte instance.
It's a write
optimization enhancement
that's required the work
of many teams at Google.
And Ted will be taking
us through that.
I think it's a really
interesting topic for us
to cover, is Cloud SQL, because
Cloud SQL, first and foremost,
makes sure that we
prioritize data integrity.
And we're going to be turning
off, or at least talking
about turning off, as part of
this conversation, a feature
in MySQL called
double-write buffer.
And when you search
on that term,
what you'll find is that
most online conversations end
with a statement
like, "don't turn
that off if you wish to
maintain data integrity."
We're going to be talking about
doing that across our fleet
and for all
production instances.
And I think it's going to be
interesting conversation for us
to have with you today, as
to why we think that's safe
and why we think it's the right
thing to do from a performance
standpoint.
Let's jump in.
And let me first
start by pointing out
where Cloud SQL is in the
overall Google database
portfolio.
Google has a fairly
broad portfolio,
as you can see on the slide.
Looking rightmost, you see
third party or partner database
offerings on Google Cloud.
Google Cloud generally has
a large partner ecosystem.
The list you see on the
rightmost side of the cloud
is not comprehensive.
There are many other--
sorry, I'm having a little
trouble with the slides here.
There are many other partner
offerings on Google Cloud.
If you look leftmost
on the slide,
you see the in-memory databases
we just recently announced
in a managed Redis service.
If you have caching needs, we
do have more offerings this year
than we did last year.
And you can expect, generally,
the database portfolio
to continue to
increase over time.
Looking just right
of center, you
see the relational
portion of the portfolio.
It's made up of Cloud
Spanner and Cloud SQL.
If you haven't checked
out Cloud Spanner
or been to one of the talks
at the conference this week,
I encourage you to
do so on Spanner.
It's a great product
to get to know.
Cloud SQL's role in the
portfolio is compatibility.
Cloud SQL is meant to offer
very standard MySQL and Postgres
compatibility.
We work hard to offer as close
to unmanaged MySQL and Postgres
as we can so that we can say,
if your application works
with MySQL or with
Postgres, it's
going to work with Cloud SQL.
Most of our talk today
will focus on MySQL,
but we'll point out a few
Postgres items, as well.
In addition to
compatibility, Cloud SQL
aims to reduce mundane
database administration that's
often associated with
running MySQL and Postgres.
And as we talk
through this, I think
pointing out what "mundane"
means is important.
When we talk about
things that are mundane--
We may have to get a
little tech help up here.
Looks like we've
got slides that are
wanting to progress as
a mind of their own.
When we talk about mundane,
we think about simple things
like telling Cloud SQL, watch
how much storage I'm using,
and as needed, increase
the amount of storage
so that I don't run out of it.
We also talk about
some advanced concepts
that we'll get into as I
look at the overall stack.
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
BRETT HESTERBERG: OK.
We'll give it a shot here.
So when you think
about Cloud SQL,
Tim Kelton from Descartes
Labs does a pretty good job
of summing it up.
He says Cloud SQL gives
his team more time
to work on products or
more time to work on things
other than database
administration that
are valuable to his customers.
And it's a good way to
think about Cloud SQL.
When I think about Cloud SQL,
I tend to picture this stack.
This stack shows a
few different columns.
Leftmost--
SPEAKER: Try just
using the space bar.
BRETT HESTERBERG: OK.
Leftmost is a stack
representing hardware.
These are servers that you're
racking and stacking, worrying
about heating and
cooling, for example.
In addition to this stack, as
you move right on the slide,
we start to think about
the operating system that
must be run on the
servers themselves
and keeping that operating
system up to date.
Moving further right, we finally
start to talk about databases.
This is the database
installation.
It's software patching on the
database, keeping it secure,
and mandatory things
like making sure we
have backup scheduled so that
we're protecting our data.
Finally, rightmost
on the slide are
some of the more advanced
concepts in the database
world--
setting up high availability
or replication for scale out,
making decisions about
when to failover,
when is a database unhealthy,
and whether we should do that
automatically or manually.
All of this, of course,
gets tied together
or plugged together
with monitoring
so that we can understand
how our stack is performing.
When I think of Cloud
SQL, I picture this stack.
And I recognize
that Cloud SQL's job
is to turn this stack into a
single API call or a few UI
clicks so that if you're a
DevOps engineer or developer,
with a single API
call, you can spin up
a very simple development
database or a much more
complex production database
with high availability
and scale out for reads.
What's not shown in this diagram
is one last important thing
about Cloud SQL.
And that is that it's backed by
Cloud SQL's 24-by-7 SRE team.
Jason from RealMassive
points this out,
that because Cloud SQL is backed
by an SRE team whose job it
is to automate and monitor--
to keep the fleet
healthy, and then
when needed put hands
on keyboards to bring up
an unhealthy database--
his team worries less,
now, about databases
and carrying the pager,
so to speak, and more
about other things
in their technology stack.
Hopefully that gives you a
little feel for Cloud SQL.
Since this is a
performance talk,
let's get into
scaling Cloud SQL.
I'm going to start with some
simple infrastructure concepts,
and then we'll get into some
real detailed, especially
MySQL-level conversation.
Scaling Cloud SQL up--
to start with, Cloud
SQL starts very small.
If you're new to Cloud
SQL, Cloud SQL instances
start at less than $10 a month.
They scale up, right now, to
64 CPU cores and more than 400
gigabytes of RAM.
These numbers change over time.
When we present again next year,
these numbers will be larger.
They were smaller last year.
So expect more cores, more
RAM, et cetera, over time.
I think scaling up with
respect to CPUs and RAM
is pretty straightforward.
What's a little
less intuitive is
how you scale storage
performance in Cloud SQL
and generally in Google Cloud.
When you're thinking about
scaling performance of storage
in Google Cloud, note that you
scale by increasing capacity.
And Cloud SQL, as you see in
the small screen shot here,
includes a
performance calculator
that shows how much storage
performance will be delivered
to your instance based
on a few factors--
how many CPU cores you
selected and the capacity
of storage you are
allocating to Cloud SQL.
What I'll note here is that
as you increase capacity,
we deliver more IOPS.
And as you can see
by the calculator,
we're only delivering about
half of the IOPS or so
that we could for this instance
based on the amount of capacity
that we've selected.
Last thing I'll note is
that managing the mundane
that I talked about earlier,
where the simple check box here
tells Cloud SQL, watch
my storage capacity.
If I'm getting too close
to filling up my disk,
grow it for me, and
do it on the fly.
Do it without taking
my database down.
So I think it's a great
way to point out--
not only how to
scale up, but also
some of managing the mundane.
OK.
You've scaled up your Cloud SQL
instance, and at some point,
your workload is so
heavy that you're not
able to continue to burden
the single instance,
and it's time to scale out.
Cloud SQL make scaling out easy
in that, again, with a few API
calls or UI clicks, you can add
replication and read replicas
so that in this
common configuration,
we can start to send
expensive read queries.
Maybe we're running
reports on Friday,
or we're using some
reporting tool.
You can send those to a replica
rather than pointing those
at the primary instance, which
is already under write load.
That way, the primary
instance can focus on
writes, and reads go
elsewhere, onto your replicas.
Just by show of hands
here, how many of you
are familiar with the
difference between MySQL's
semi-synchronous
replication and MySQL's
asynchronous replication?
A handful of people.
A number didn't
raise their hands,
so I'll give you the
one-minute overview.
Semi-synchronous replication
requires that a primary
instance and a standby
instance-- a replica--
both write a transaction
before that transaction
is acknowledged to
the application.
So an application says,
"here's my transaction"
to the primary instance.
The primary instance,
when replicating
using semi-synchronous
replication,
commits that transaction itself.
And it waits for the replica to
acknowledge that it's written
the transaction to a relay log.
The replica doesn't have to
actually commit the transaction
to data files.
As long as it's
written to a relay log,
the replica will let the primary
instance know, OK, I've got it.
And the primary instance then
comes back to the application
and says, OK, I'm ready
for your next transaction.
This has, I think, two
important characteristics.
One is that, in the
event of a failover,
we know that both our
primary and standby instance
have the data.
We're not going to lose
data on a failover.
And for that reason,
Cloud SQL employs it
as the only way we
replicate for a failover
replica, the only
way we replicate
for high availability.
The second characteristic is
performance overhead-- right,
this is obvious.
We're sending a write not
only to the primary instance
but also to this secondary
or standby instance.
And we're waiting for both
to say, "OK, I've got it"
before we let the application
write another transaction.
This differs from
asynchronous replication
in that in asynchronous
replication,
the primary instance
will happily
continue to take transaction
after transaction
without waiting for the replica
to tell it, "OK, I've got it,"
as well.
In this way, you
can have a replica
that doesn't have the
very latest transactions
that the primary instance has.
Cloud SQL uses
asynchronous replication
only for read replicas.
These are your scale
out read replicas.
Again, for failover, we're
using semi-synchronous
so we can guarantee we don't
lose data when we failover.
We also, with a
failover replica,
ensure that we put it
in a separate zone--
a separate failure
domain, if you will--
within a region so that we
have higher fault tolerance.
With a read replica
or for read scale out
where we're using
asynchronous, we
let you put those
anywhere you want.
And again, we don't
use them for failover.
So what you see in this diagram
is a very common configuration.
I have a high-availability
configuration.
I have semi-synchronous
replication
between my primary instance
and my failover replica.
And I've also added
an asynchronous read
replica for read scale out.
So I'm moving read load
off of my primary instance
so that it can
focus on write load.
And this is what we're
talking about when we talk
about Cloud SQL scaling out.
Now, an important note here
is that while Cloud SQL makes
all of this an
API call and makes
scaling up and
scaling out easy, it
doesn't tell you when to scale.
And that's important
because it still
requires you to know
your database numbers.
What you see in
this screenshot is
Cloud SQL showing you
a basic set of metrics
in the cloud console.
In addition to those
metrics, we, in Cloud SQL,
enable the INNODB_METRICS table.
I encourage you to get
to know that table.
It contains a wealth of
performance information
about MySQL and
will help you make
decisions about when
to scale up and when
to eventually scale out.
With that in mind,
let's take a look back.
And I'll ask Stanley to
take us back to Next 2017
and talk to us about
what's changed since then.
Let me, actually, take
that back from you.
STANLEY FENG: Take back
the slide first, yeah.
BRETT HESTERBERG: If we have
trouble with the advancing,
we'll move it back over here.
STANLEY FENG: OK.
SPEAKER: What it is is
we're getting interference
from another clicker somewhere.
So if we could stick
with the space bar.
BRETT HESTERBERG: OK.
STANLEY FENG: OK.
BRETT HESTERBERG: I'll
advance your slides for you.
STANLEY FENG: I can do that.
So let's take a look at
the Cloud SQL performance.
We do need the pointer, though.
It's OK.
I'll just wave my hands, then.
So let's take a look at the
Cloud SQL performance in 2017.
What's shown here is a
typical sysbench OLTP run.
What we run is a step
load kind of test,
with each step doubling the
load of the previous step.
We started with one test
thread, and then two, then four,
then eight, and then
all the way to 512.
What's plotted here is TPS,
Transaction Per Second.
And each step runs
for about 20 minutes.
And for every second
of those 20 minutes,
we collect the TPS data
and then plot it here.
So this you're going to see a
number of these kind of graphs
throughout the presentation.
This is our standard way of
benchmarking and plotting
results.
The benefit of this
is, you will be
able to see a lot of variability
throughout this 20-minute run,
because every second of the
data is displayed on this chart.
So what you see here
is, the red line
is our performance
in February 2017.
And the green line is the
performance in August 2017.
And there are two main reasons
for these kind of improvements.
One is, we did some
level of database,
and especially InnoDB
tuning, to stabilize
the performance of our
database and to allow
the underlying storage
performance improvement
to show up as a database layer.
The second fundamental reason
for this kind of improvement
is because Persistent
Disk has made
a lot of performance
improvements
in both latency and throughput.
Remember that Cloud SQL is built
on top of Google Cloud Platform
and uses Persistent Disk as an
underlying storage foundation.
Next slide.
And you can see similar graph
for the Cloud SQL Postgres
performance.
And this one is for Postgres HA.
And the blue line
is February 2017.
And the green line
is November 2017.
And for a similar reason, we
are seeing about 2x improvement
in our end performance.
So then, you might
wonder, what about 2018
and this data for 2017 one
year ago, and what about now?
And actually, I encourage you
guys to find out by yourself.
Please feel free to take
pictures of this slide,
because there is some
information here.
So one tool I
really, really want
to bring up to your
attention is a tool
called Perfkit Benchmarker.
So basically, we
decided to open-source
all of our benchmarking
code-- not just
database, but also compute,
storage, and everything--
into a tool called
Perfkit Benchmarker.
And it's available on GitHub.
For the database-related
one, it's
called ManagerRelationalDB.py.
That would be the
starting point.
And the fundamental
reason we want
to open-source our
benchmarking tool
is to be purely open
and transparent.
So you get to see exactly
what we are benchmarking as.
You get to read the code.
You get to see how we
set up the framework.
You get to see what
kind of parameters
we're passing through the tools.
You get to see what
kind of tools we use.
And we actually cause into
sysbench and a pgbench
when doing this kind
of benchmarking.
So there's a benefit of
using Perfkit Benchmarkers.
You can use exactly the same
tool and the same methodology
on other providers and find
out the numbers by yourself
and make your judgment.
So our canonical
test configuration,
when you decide to try
the Perfkit Benchmarker,
our canonical test
configuration is basically,
we always try to make sure
the data set is large.
So it's 5x RAM.
And we use n1-standard-16.
And we always try
to fully provision
the underlying storage,
which it should
be 1.7 terabytes for PDSSD
and for the best performance
possible.
And then we place
the test client
in the same zone
as the database,
and we run each load step
for long enough so we
get to observe the variability.
So next slide.
And then, besides the
benchmarking tools
and we open-sourced, we
also published our tuning
parameters.
And again, please feel
free to take pictures here.
And there's a tinyurl
to the lower right
part of the presentation.
And it shows a number
of InnoDB flags
retuned to achieve the
effect of the left-hand side.
As you can see, the performance
effect of the left-hand side
is more stable, more consistent
than the right-hand side.
And the documentation also
describes and explains
the justifications
and reasons for why
we tune each of those flags.
So next slide.
Now, looking ahead,
what is next?
So today, we're going to spend
quite a bit of our time in this
presentation talking about a
problem we want to tackle--
we have tried to tackle,
in the last few months--
or quarters, actually.
The problem is about
scaling writes at a very
high concurrency load.
Now, high concurrency--
high is always
in the context of
some definition.
So here, we target sysbench
concurrency test thread at 512.
So what's shown here is
an eight-hour long run
of sysbench OLTP at 512 threads.
As you can see, the
database performance
varies by at least 3x.
It can go as high as about
3,000, and drops down to 1,100
for the first half of the test.
And then for the second
half of the test,
it drops down to about
a couple of hundred--
like 100 to 200--
from time to time.
So with this kind of
variability in database,
for many developers,
the database
will be deemed essentially
useless because, first of all,
it's hard to the
capacity planning
with this kind of performance.
And second is that, for
those deep dips of TPS
during the second
half of the test,
it easily can translate into
timeouts from the application
server.
So basically, a
performance problem
would turn into an
availability problem.
And the third one is, if a
database is an important piece
of a critical user journey or
user experience-- for example,
populating some of
the fields on the UI,
or saving some
temporary states as user
going through a
set of bylog or UIs
to complete something
end-to-end--
then this kind of
performance will
lead to pretty bad overall user
experience for the application.
So let's take a look why
that problem happens.
Where, exactly, is the problem?
So what's plotted here is
what we call InnoDB flush lag.
So for those of you who
have read into the InnoDB
and the way the
InnoDB handles writes,
basically, each writes,
when InnoDB process a write
and it writes the
transaction to the redo log.
And as soon as the transaction
is committed to the redo log,
the transaction will be
considered successful.
Meanwhile, the data page in
memory will also be modified.
But the datapicture will
be flushed asynchronously
at the backend to the data file.
Now, what's plotted here
is called a flush lag.
That is a difference in bytes
between the latest write that
has been successfully
committed to the redo log
minus the oldest write that is
in memory that still has not
been flushed to data file yet.
The flush log is generally equal
to the size of the redo log.
Now, in general, most of
the database-- or almost
all database, especially
MySQL, has a limit
on the size of the redo log,
because if the redo log is
too large, it will affect
your crash recovery time.
So when InnoDB sees a flush
log, or the size of the redo log
grows approaching the limit--
by default, it's at around
80% to 82% of that limit--
then that is plotted as
a horizontal red line
on this chart.
That is when the InnoDB
will go into what
they call a sync flush state.
What a sync flush
state means, that
is when the flush log
or the redo log size
is at, in this
case, 820 megabytes.
Then, when the next
notation comes in,
InnoDB will not
process a notation,
but instead, it will go into
its in-memory dirty pages,
find out if the
oldest dirty pages
were flushed,
successfully flush,
and writes that dirty
page into the data file
first, [INAUDIBLE] the
corresponding space
in the redo log.
Then, it will take
that new notation.
So this forms a stop-and-go
pattern in the end TPS graph,
as we see.
And this is the
fundamental reason
why you're seeing this kind
of performance variability.
That, going to
the next slide, is
we're going to see how we
can control the flush lag.
So as you can see,
flush lag is how much
lag the dirty page flush is
behind incoming notation rate.
So logically, it
seems very simple.
If you want to
control flush lag,
you just want to make
sure that database
can flush dirty pages at
the rate that is higher
than incoming write rate.
So there are two angles
to tackle this problem.
One is, if you stop
incoming writes--
you have zero writes-- then you
will not have high flush lag.
But that's not acceptable.
We want to make sure
that our instance can
support as high an incoming
write rate as possible.
So the next angle
to attack this is
to make sure the database
can flush dirty pages as
fast as possible.
So there's a concept
called InnoDB doublewrite.
Obviously, if you
disable doublewrite,
you basically cut the write
load during dirty page
by half, essentially doubling
the rate the database can
flush the dirty pages.
Now, we're going to talk
more about what is InnoDB
doublewrite in the next slide.
So for those of
you who have never
heard of InnoDB doublewrite,
this is a quick refresh.
It's basically,
InnoDB doublewrite
does exactly what its
name says-- double
write, write twice.
So when InnoDB wants
to flush a dirty page,
it writes each dirty page
twice, sequentially--
first to the
doublewrite buffer, then
to the actual
place in data file.
Then why?
Why does it do that?
Why does it have to do that?
So it has to deal with a
concept called torn writes.
A torn write is a
on-disk data page that
is partly new and partly old.
It happens when the write
operation of a 16 KB data page
was interrupted in the middle
of the write for any reason.
Then, when the
torn write happens,
then the only way to
recover from a torn write
is to take that backup data
page from the doublewrite buffer
and use that to
recover torn write.
You cannot use redo log
to recover torn page
because to replay redo log,
you have to have the original,
old page in its correct
form to replay the redo log.
But with the torn page, you have
a page that is some part new,
some part old that you simply
cannot recover unless you have
a backup copy of that page--
which is why InnoDB
has to do doublewrite.
So then the next question go
a little bit step deeper--
how could a torn page,
torn write, happen?
There are two major reasons
for a torn write to happen.
When there's a disk--
so any traditional
disks generally
do not have atomic writes.
And they can write at
512 byte sector size.
And many disks have 4
KB physical block size.
Even if they support
atomic writes,
it would be at 4 KB boundary.
And for a 16 KB data
page, that means
that if it's anything that
fails during the 16 KB data
page write, only part of that
might be written to the disk.
That's the first reason.
Second reason is a file system.
Now, let's say you
have physical disks
that you buy special hardware
that can support 16 KB
atomic writes.
The file system still
has to do some magic
to make sure that the writes are
sent to disk at 16 KB aligned
boundary.
So in general, most of the
file system ext4 are those.
They have 4 KB as
a data page size.
And even the Linux kernel
has 4 KB as a page size.
That means files
are only guaranteed
to align at 4 KB boundaries.
Now, if a file that is aligned
only at 4 KB boundary, but it
not aligned at 16 KB
boundary, then a 16 KB
write into the file may actually
span two physical blocks
on disk, which is going
to break atomicity, again.
So-- next slide--
the solution we come up
with to tackle this problem,
to allow us to safely
disable InnoDB doublewrite,
is to try to achieve 16 KB
atomic writes in our storage
stack from top to the
bottom, end to end.
So first, I can introduce these
layers from bottom to the top,
actually.
First of all, we have
worked with very closely
with the Persistent Disk team
to create a 16 KB physical block
size PD that will provide
physical block level write
atomicity.
So I want to call out
this, because this
is very unique and
special in GCP,
that there are some prior
arts in the industry you have
to purchase special hardware.
But with GCP, all you have
to do is to press up arrow
of your keyboard-- which
I suppose you have typed
in GCloud before--
and then add a new parameter
called physical block
size equal to 16 KB.
Enter.
You have a special disk that's
about 16 KB atomic writes.
So the next layer of the
stack that we worked on,
which that, we'll talk
a lot more in detail,
is we configured and used a
new, innovative feature in ext4
called BigAlloc.
With BigAlloc, we forced file
system allocate and align files
at 16 KB boundary.
And the third one is that to
ensure that the Linux kernel
block layer file
system do not split
writes into 16 KB
boundary, we worked
with our
Container-Optimized OS team
to introduce extensive
regression and qualification
test, and to ensure that when
upstream changes the kernel
code, we catch those
invariants that were broken,
and we make sure that the
OS itself does not break.
The fourth one that we
actually also worked
with GC virtualization
teams to make
sure some of the critical
parameters in virtio layers
are configured properly.
Mainly, it's max segment
size and maxed sectors KB.
And there have to be
certain invariants
for the kernel to not split
writes into 16 KB boundary.
The last one, at
the top level, is
that with powers, we have to
config InnoDB to use O_DIRECT.
So with that, I would like to
invite Ted onto stage to talk
about container optimize--
oh, sorry.
There's two more slides here.
So I want to show the effect
of disabling doublewrites.
As you can see if you
recall the flush lag graph.
And previously, it was hitting
the red line consistently.
This is with the 16 KB feature.
As you can see, we are able
to effectively suppress
a flush lag well
below the red line.
And the next slide shows the
TPS result. Showing you here,
on the middle of the
chart, is the TPS running
exactly the same load--
eight hour and 512 threads.
And the performance is generally
pretty stable and consistent.
And the lower right corner was
doing 4 KB and doublewrite on.
So sorry, Ted.
Here.
TED TSO: All right.
So before I start--
is my mic on?
Excellent.
So before we continue
the story of how
we're able to enable the
16 K instance feature,
I want to take a brief
detour and talk a little bit
about Container-Optimized OS.
Some of you may have heard
about Container-Optimized OS,
also known as COS, because it's
the preferred recommended image
for Google Kubernetes Engine.
It's basically a
stripped-down Linux operating
system that has a
security-hardened kernel,
verified boot.
And since it's stripped down,
it has just the software
you need so we can minimize
its attack surface.
Since it's based on the
open-source Chromium OS,
we have a very
rapid release cycle.
And that's important
for two reasons.
The first is, we can
get security fixes out
and into COS very rapidly.
And the second is,
it also allowed
us to get new features,
new innovations deployed
very rapidly.
And not only is
it the recommended
image for Kubernetes
Engine, we also
use it as the basis for
Cloud SQL's virtual machines.
And so that's how we actually
deployed the kernel changes
and some of the
user space changes
we needed to support
this particular feature.
So just to review, there
are two kernel guarantees
that we have to be
able to make in order
to make sure that 16 K database
pages don't get partially
written to the disk in the
case of some kind of instance
failure or hardware failure.
And the first is that we need
to make sure that the database
files are laid out in
logical chunks that
are 16 kilobytes--
what we call clusters.
And I'll talk more about
that on the next slide.
And then the second thing
we need to make sure
is that these I/O requests
don't get broken up
into multiple
requests, since that
might lead to a torn write
in a failure scenario.
So to accomplish
the first thing,
we used a file system
feature called BigAlloc.
It was originally developed
to optimize write patterns
for large-scale cluster file
systems such as Google's GFS.
And what it does is it
works around a restriction
in the Linux virtual machine
which does not allow the file
system block size to be larger
than the page size, which,
on Intel x86
architectures, is only 4 K.
And so therefore, we can't make
the block size larger than 4 K.
So what we do instead
is we introduce
a new concept, called clusters.
And clusters are
composed of a power
of 2 number of 4 K blocks.
And data files get allocated
in units of clusters.
We still send the writes
out in 4 K blocks,
but the file system tracks
them in 16 K clusters.
And this feature has been
around for quite a while.
It actually hit the mainline
Linux kernel in 2011.
But it only had been used for
very restricted use cases.
As I said, the original
use case of this
was for large-scale
cluster file systems.
And so when we looked
at what we would
need to do in order to
enable this feature for use
in Cloud SQL, there
were two things
that we decided we had to do
to make it be production-ready.
The first is that we had to add
support for online resizing.
This is so, as your database
grows and you have a need
to store more data, Cloud
SQL will make a request
to the persistent
disk to grow the size
of the persistent disk.
And we need to be
able to grow the file
system to use that extra space
for the expanded persistent
disk.
And then the second
thing we needed to do
is, we had to add extensive
regression testing to make sure
that all of the new corner
cases that Cloud SQL might use
were actually exercised
in our regression testing
in the COS kernel to
make sure that there
weren't any problems.
Because even though
this BigAlloc feature
has been around for
a long time, it's not
a very commonly-used feature.
And so there was the possibility
that there were corner cases
that no one had
noticed, might not
have been working quite right.
So for the second requirement
of what we needed to do,
we had to audit the
Linux I/O stack.
Historically, all operating
systems, including Linux,
will merge adjacent
requests in order
to make things more efficient.
And then, if there are
limitations in either the SCSI
controller or the
actual SCSI disk,
it might break requests
in two in order
to deal with those limitations.
And we had to make sure that
each layer in the I/O stack--
starting at the
file system layer,
to the Linux block layer,
to the Linux SCSI layer,
to the virtio SCSI driver--
all did not do what they're
allowed to do historically,
which is to break requests up,
to make sure that if they did,
they only broke them
at 16 K boundaries.
And so that required
doing extensive audit
of all of those code paths.
And after we did that, we had
to ask ourselves the question,
so what if future Linux
kernels might make changes
in the storage stack
and all that auditing
work might no longer be valid
for some new upstream kernel?
And so what we did is we
added additional regression
tests that actually tested
to make sure that writes
would never get broken up
at inconvenient boundaries.
And we added that to our
continuous testing regime
that we use as part of our
build and release process
for the kernels for
Container-Optimized OS.
And that's to make sure that
this guarantee that we've
made after auditing
the code will
continue to be true in
future Linux kernels.
And so the main thing, the
final point I want to make here,
is that this effort
required collaboration
across a large number
of teams at Google--
the Cloud SQL team, the
Container-Optimized OS team,
the Persistent Disk team, and
the GCE virtualization team.
We all work together in order
to make this feature possible.
And it's sort of a testimony
to the sort of things
we can do when we take
really good people working
at multiple layers
across the product
to produce a feature like this.
And back to Brett.
BRETT HESTERBERG: That's
a great point, Ted.
So to summarize a little bit
and talk about next steps,
we'll wrap up here
with just a few points.
When you think about scaling
Cloud SQL, start simple.
As I mentioned, scaling up is
intuitive-- except, perhaps,
that scaling storage is aligned
with scaling its capacity.
So note that capacity and
performance have a relationship
in Google Cloud generally,
and in Cloud SQL.
Look forward, of course,
to larger instance
types and continued storage
performance improvements.
All the numbers on the slides
that we showed, hopefully.
will be outdated in
some number of months.
The commitment that Cloud
SQL has, in addition
to being compatible--
which I mentioned
is, your application just works
with Cloud SQL-- additionally,
we also are committed
to being open.
And I think that shows
up in a few ways.
Stanley mentioned that
our Perfkit Benchmarker
is fully open-sourced.
You see the tinyurl there.
We host it on GitHub.
We encourage you
to run it yourself.
It should help you set up a
test environment, should allow
you to compare Cloud SQL
against other database services,
or a database that
you're running yourself.
And it allows you,
because it's open source,
to change the test parameters--
make them look more
like your workloads.
The other thing that
Stanley pointed out
is, when we tune a
database, we tune it
not only for ourselves
but, hopefully,
we tune it for everyone.
And we've posted, for the past
couple of years, our tuning
parameters.
There's Cloud SQL,
on the third bullet
point you see on the slide,
which is the bottom URL.
I encourage you, if you're
not running Cloud SQL on GCP,
to start with our
tuning parameters,
if you're going to run
MySQL of your own accord,
maybe on a Compute
Engine VM, and then
continue tuning from there.
Our parameters will give
you better performance
than a default
MySQL installation
will on Compute Engine.
And we think it's a
great starting point,
if nothing else, for you.
Ted talked about what it took
to align teams within Google so
that we can safely turn
off doublewrite buffer
and produce what we've
called 16 KB instances.
If you have interest in
seeing those for yourself
in Cloud SQL, please send an
email to this email address.
We have started an
active alpha program.
You're more than welcome to join
to see how write optimization
may benefit your workload.
What you'll also see
from the Google teams
is that we'll make these
options available to you
if you're choosing to run MySQL
outside of Cloud SQL, as well.
So if you're using
Container-Optimized OS--
and, as Stanley mentioned, you
can configure Persistent Disk
with 16 KB block size--
you'll be able to benefit
from this yourself
as long as you stay within
some of the parameters.
As you can see, there was a
lot of work from Linux kernel
down through the storage stack
to make sure this is safe.
But we're going to
do our best to make
this open, like the rest of
Cloud SQL, to you, as well.
I want to point out a
couple presentation picks.
We're on, really, kind
of the first major day
of the conference.
I'm going to give you two
shameless plugs to start out.
First, we have a "Best Practices
for Migrating to Cloud SQL"
session tomorrow afternoon.
If you're interested
in migrating
a workload to Cloud SQL,
stop by and take a look
at this session.
It'll talk about how to do
that, especially to MySQL,
with low downtime.
Just later this afternoon,
we're doing an introduction
to Cloud SQL and Kubernetes.
If you'd like to learn
more about Kubernetes
and how it can work
with Cloud SQL,
take a look at this
session, which is just
after today's session here.
And last on the
list is IO225, which
is "What's New with Spanner."
If you haven't been
introduced to Spanner,
I think this is a good
session to pick up what's new.
And it will, of course, give
a bit of a product overview
on Spanner, as well.
With that, on behalf
of Stanley and Ted,
I want to thank you for spending
the last 42 minutes with us
and for bearing with a few
slight hiccups along the way.
We'd love to open things
up to your questions.
And if we run out of
time for questions,
we'll ask that some
of our Cloud SQL folks
stay toward the
front of the room
so that you can catch up
with us after the session.
Thank you, everyone.